thank you
it's 10 o'clock this is Sky News at 10
our top story
[Music]
the final moments of the Nashville
School attack caught on police body cam
as the U.S president calls again for a
ban on weapons of war
the shooter Audrey Hale stalks the
corridors killing six people with
legally bought weapons
tonight the local Congressman remaining
Unapologetic for posting this image of
his wife and three children why would I
regret taking a family photo with my
family and exercising my constitutional
rights
also tonight Prince Harry accuses the
royal family of failing to back him in
his privacy fight against the publisher
of the Daily Mail
the toxic culture of bullying at one of
the country's biggest Hospital trusts
which one family says LED his Junior
doctor to take her own life
be vigilant but not alarmed Northern
Ireland's Terror Threat Level is raised
to severe
thus we will not be bullied the message
from a U.S warship Commander to Beijing
over the South China Sea
and we'll take a first look at
tomorrow's front pages that's in our
press preview from 10 30.
[Music]
hello good evening it is Testament to
just how endemic mass shootings are in
the United States the school massacres
have now become all too common but today
body cam footage of armed police racing
through empty classrooms at Covenant
School in Nashville Tennessee while
alarms sounded brings home the full
horror of those fatal moments they
eventually shoot and kill the attacker
28 year old Audrey Hale that too is
caught on camera by then six people were
dead two teachers a caretaker and three
nine-year-old pupils we'll begin tonight
at the scene of America's
131st mass casualty event this year a
U.S correspondent Martha Kellner is in
Nashville Martha
yeah the entrance to Covenant Christian
School behind me has become the focal
point for a community's grief today just
in the past few moments a group has
arrived to place six white crosses at
the entrance to the school to
commemorate each of the six victims of
this attack all the while we're learning
new horrific details about what unfolded
inside police now say that the killer
had managed to legally obtain seven
different guns in recent years from
different shops in Tennessee we also
know the killer was being treated for
mental health issues by a doctor but
that wasn't known to law enforcement a
warning my report contains distressing
images of the final moments of this
attack
in a country where school shootings
happen almost once a week this is what
police have been training for
[Music]
okay okay
inside almost 200 staff and primary
school children are hiding
[Music]
satchels are still in cubby holes
workbooks on tables
sounds
office go classroom to classroom in
Pursuit with me
next
series
[Music]
at this point they don't know who the
shooter is or if there's more than one
in fact a 28 year old former student had
broken in through a locked side door
shooting through the glass and climbing
in this is Audrey Hale born a woman and
identifying as a man they know and have
studied the layout of this building over
the course of 14 minutes stalking the
corridors hail shoots dead three
children and three adults
[Applause]
[Music]
floor police follow the sound of gunfire
the shooter is visible for the first
time
then they're gone suspect down suspect
down
killed inside Covenant School where head
teacher Catherine Koontz caretaker Mike
Hill and substitute teacher Cynthia Peak
Hallie Scruggs the nine-year-old
daughter of the school's Pastor was also
murdered
alongside two of her classmates William
Kinney and evening decaus
there's a lot of Praise here for the
Swift police response but clearly it
wasn't soon enough to save those six
victims and so there's a lot of
soul-searching too about America's gun
laws
this is the Christmas card of one of the
people who represents Nashville in
government Congressman Andy ogles posing
with his children holding assault rifles
like the one used in this shooting
but when questioned by Sky News he was
Unapologetic why would I regret taking a
family photo with my family and
exercising my constitutional rights
President Biden called once more for a
ban on these weapons of war it was
echoed here too
because
a lot of lives we send them to school in
the morning and we don't know if we are
going to pick them up in the afternoon
everyone here hopes it will not happen
to their school their supermarket their
City this is Nashville's tragedy the
latest but almost certainly not the last
the police don't know or at least they
haven't disclosed yet a motive for this
attack they do believe that the school
was targeted the killer of course a
former pupil here but they don't as yet
think that any of the victims were
specifically targeted Justin in the past
few minutes we've received a statement
from the family of Mike Hill the
caretaker killed in that attack his
family say he was a father of seven and
a grandfather of 14 who loved to cook
and spend time with his family they say
they hope the thoughts of this community
and of this nation are with them and the
other victims
the personal cost of another school
shooting mother in Nashville thank you
Prince Harry arrived at the high court
today for a second day and said in a
witness statement that the royal family
withheld phone hacking information from
him as they didn't want him to in his
words open a can of worms the Duke of
Sussex made the claims as part of his
civil case against Associated newspapers
Publishers of the Daily Mail Katie
Spencer was there
back for the second day running and for
the first time an insight into why the
Duke of Sussex flew Halfway Around the
World to be here with his and his fellow
complainants witness statements made
public an insight into what they all
knew and when Prince Harry claiming two
private investigators have said the mail
paid them to hack his voicemail obtain
credit card bills and follow his friends
going on to say that the palace withheld
what was going on from him the
institution made it clear that we did
not need to know anything about phone
hacking and it was made clear to me that
the royal family did not sit in the
witness box because that could open up a
can of worms
from actress Sadie Frost an explanation
of how she felt suicidal and humiliated
at the personal level of detail revealed
in the mail baroness Lawrence whose son
Stephen was murdered alleging she was
subject to voicemail hacking her bank
accounts monitored and subject to Hidden
electronic surveillance as the
Publishers of the Daily Mail fight to
get the throne out of court they say
that a private investigator's alleged
confessions which provides a central
part of the claimants case has since
provided them with a sworn statement
saying that he wasn't commissioned or
instructed to carry out any work for the
Daily Mail and they vigorously contest
the claims that are being made here in
Court Prince Harry also went on to
explain why he thinks what he describes
as a cover-up needs to go to trial
saying if the most influential newspaper
company can successfully evade Justice
then in my opinion the whole country is
doomed while the written statements from
Prince Harry and his fellow claimants
may be powerful and express how they
felt about alleged attacking the
publisher of the mail continues to
maintain that their claims have been
brought too late to have their day in
court Katie Spencer Sky News
more policing a review of one of
England's biggest NHS trusts has found a
culture of bullying so ingrained it
could put patient care at risk the
report was ordered after the death of a
junior Doctor Who took her own life
citing a toxic work environment today
vaish Kumar's father told Sky News that
he feared other staff are equally Under
Pressure he was speaking to our Midlands
correspondent Becky Johnson tell me
about your plans for year 35. thanks to
stay healthy
happy Dr vaish Kumar was bright happy
and looking forward to the future
but when she began working here at the
Queen Elizabeth Hospital in Birmingham
things changed at a trust now exposed
for a toxic culture of bullying Dr Kumar
was belittled and laughed at and would
often go home in tears she took her own
life last summer and left a note for her
parents blaming the hospital
each day is a struggle it's
it makes me angry
and at the same time
worried about the other Junior doctors
who are going to follow her the report
found Dr Kumar was not the first doctor
at this trust to take her own life it
highlighted a long-standing bullying and
toxic environment where staff via
retribution if concerns were raised and
warns any continuance of a culture that
is corrosively affecting morale and in
particular threatens long-term staff
Recruitment and Retention will put at
risk the care of patients
this trust has a patient death rate
that's 10 percent higher than would be
expected the report found that if the
culture here isn't already affecting
mortality rates it's likely it is
affecting the treatment that patients
receive
consultant eye surgeon Tristan rooser
won a case of unfair dismissal against
the trust
a former Chief Executive had referred
him to the General Medical Council
without mentioning he was a
whistleblower who'd raised concerns
about unsafe Staffing levels the current
permit members of the board have been
part of the culture of fear and the
mafia-like culture unless they go
nothing will change they're all part of
the same culture they have to go
the new chief executive insists concerns
are being addressed we are listening I
am listening I have done so much
listening so much engagement about all
of the things that people are unhappy
about in this organization I am
committed to making sure that we change
but this report paints a damning picture
of one of England's largest NHS trusts
Becky Johnson Sky News Birmingham
MI5 has raised the terror threat in
Northern Ireland to severe meaning an
attack is highly likely less than two
weeks before the 25th anniversary of the
Good Friday agreement Northern Ireland
secretary Chris Heaton Harris said a
small number of people were determined
to cause harm through politically
motivated violence Sky's Island
correspondent Stephen Murphy reports
a time for celebration but also a time
of increased danger as the 25th
anniversary of the Belfast or Good
Friday agreement looms a stark reminder
that the peace had secured remains a
fragile one the security service MI5
today raised the terror threat in
Northern Ireland to severe meaning an
attack there is highly likely the psni
supported by Partners will relentlessly
pursue those who seek to cause harm and
terrorize our community and those who
seek to attack police officers and other
members of the security services here in
Northern Ireland MI5 doesn't explain its
decisions but the move comes a month
after the attempted murder of DCI John
Caldwell and Omar the shooting suspected
to be the work of the new Ira the
detective remains in critical condition
and it comes on the brink of a visit to
Ireland North and South by President Joe
Biden as the U.S leader marks the
anniversary of Northern Ireland's peace
agreement there is a small but
reasonably potent group of terrorists
who would be intent on using the
opportunity to Garner attention for
themselves when the world's gaze would
be in Ireland so with that awareness MI5
would have had no choice but to take
this this is prudent precaution taking
Northern Ireland of course has been here
before the Threat Level was at severe
for 12 years from 2010 to just last year
it was reduced to substantial just over
12 months ago after decreased levels of
dissident Republican activity now it's
back to the second highest Threat Level
Possible A lot has changed in Northern
Ireland in the last quarter Century but
some things have not the threat of
violence from those supposed to be
consigned to the Past still lingers and
will cast a shadow over the celebration
of Peace Stephen Murphy Sky News
the Betting Company William Hill has
been handed a record fine after
Regulators found a series of what's
described as widespread and alarming
failings the gambling commission
described how one Gambler lost 23 000
pounds online in 20 minutes and today a
recovering gambling addict described
losing thousands himself even after
asking one company to block his beds our
business correspondent gerprit nawan
reports
money is rarely the greatest loss
there's relationships that were ruined
it ruined my career it Stripped Away all
of my life prospects James is one of
thousands across the country who have
battled a gambling addiction these
stacks of paper are his losses to just
one company during a 12-year addiction
that started when he was just 16.
campaigners and recovering addicts like
him are demanding tougher regulation and
fast there's too much Reliance on
individuals with a mental health
condition an addiction to stop gambling
and that's naive actually there needs to
be much better regulation that means the
gambling companies aren't encouraging
people to gamble more than they can
afford to or incentivizing what is
essentially an illness rules do exist
but they are routinely flouted in the
latest case William Hill was fined a
record 19.2 million pounds for allowing
customers to bet thousands of pounds
without any checks and weak anti-money
laundering controls a brand new customer
near account opened lost 23 000 pounds
in 20 minutes another loss just under 15
000 pounds in 70 minutes another 32 000
pounds in two days that sort of thing is
unacceptable
in the last year alone more than 76
million pounds was paid out
the regulatory failures
visit working but while gambling
companies continue to make bumper
profits campaigners and bereaved
families are still waiting for a long
promised overhaul of the country's
betting laws
Britain has the world's largest
regulated online gambling industry
a white paper outlining new laws was
promised in December 2020 but it has
been repeatedly delayed
when published it's expected to include
a ban on so-called VIP packages on
betting sites tighter Financial controls
and a levy on gambling companies to help
fund treatment and awareness programs we
need to have a much more aggressive
position from the commission which is
based very clearly on what they are
failing to do and the Damage that it
causes to lives so the white paper will
deal with that it's been 18 years since
this country's gambling laws were
updated for people like James tougher
regulation couldn't come soon enough
Sky News
MCU South has been formally elected as
Scotland's new first Minister after
succeeding Nicholas sturgeon as SNP
leader yesterday but he faced his first
challenge when his main leadership rival
Kate Forbes turned down a place in his
cabinet after she was offered a lower
ranking ministerial role in his
acceptance speech Mr Youssef said he
hoped his election to the top job in
Scottish politics would send a strong
message to people who felt they did not
belong
after 9 11 were not easy for Muslims
growing up in Scotland or indeed across
the UK I've lost count of how many times
my identity my loyalty to Scotland the
only country I have ever and will ever
call home has been questioned over the
years
there was a time not all that long ago
when I fell I simply did not belong here
in Scotland
to grow to go from there to now leading
the government as Scotland's sixth first
Minister I hope sends a strong message
to every single person out there who
feels that they don't belong and as
first Minister I will always fight for
your rights and where possible I will do
everything I can to advance them
demonstrations are again being held
across France against the government's
plans to raise the pension age with
fears they could escalate into
widespread violence thirteen thousand
police officers have been deployed to
contain the protests with one Minister
alleging that radical troublemakers are
trying to latch onto peaceful protests
at least 39 people have died in a fire
at a detention center for migrants in
northern Mexico near to the U.S border
with El Paso in Texas 29 others were
injured in the incident Mexico's
president said the fire started after
migrants who feared deportation set
mattresses Ablaze in protest
now when the Afghan Capital Kabul fell
more than a year ago the UK promised a
place of Refuge to those who risked
their lives to help British forces today
ministers confirmed that more than 9 000
refugees living in hotels would be asked
to leave within three months if they did
not accept new housing Charities warned
the move cuddly families already the
victims of trauma and upheaval destitute
and homeless one woman told Sky News
that she'd likely ignore any eviction
order as our communities correspondent
Lisa Holland reports
the second question what do you do
before breakfast English lessons help
Afghan evacuees in West London integrate
into the local community for this woman
who doesn't want to be identified after
more than 18 months in a nearby Hotel It
Feels Like Home which is why she won't
leave the area
if they want to send me outside of
London I will continue staying at the
hotel it's better than living somewhere
I don't have any support network or
friends I go to these classes and the
women's group and I'm used to living
here if I'm just sent in the middle of
nowhere it'll be difficult for me to
start from zero again
at the end of April the 8 000 Afghan
evacuees still living in hotel
accommodation will be given three months
notice to leave and it seems if they
refuse an offer of housing which could
be anywhere they'll be on their own at a
time when there are many pressures on
the taxpayer and the housing market it
is not right that people can choose to
stay in hotels when are the perfectly
suitable accommodation is available
at his church in Newport pagnell in
buckinghamshire Pastor Steve Wood
welcomed some of the first Afghan
evacuees to arrive in the UK of course
there are hard choices I would just want
to see the government deliver what it
promised to deliver from day one which
was that warm welcome so you moved here
from the hotel yes Afghan evacuee frazan
and her family were moved from a hotel
into this service department they aren't
part of the controversial Hotel
statistics yet they're still waiting for
something permanent and hope they won't
be forgotten we had a very high standard
of life in the country but we feel here
like a bigger is this how you thought it
would be I don't know that most of
Avalon family who were living with us
and same Hotel some of them shifted to
London some of them shifted to
Birmingham some of them shifted to
Liverpool this announcement is about
Afghan refugees who were evacuated when
Taliban retook control
but the government has also pledged to
reduce the six million pounds a day
spent housing 45
000 Asylum seekers in hotels including
those who cross the channel in small
boats Lisa Holland Sky News
well illegal migration one of Rishi cnx
key priorities was on the agenda today
when he was questioned by a committee of
senior cross party MPS for the Prime
Minister stuck to his hard line where
perhaps of how that would be received by
many voters in the key constituencies
which will determine whether he stays in
Downing Street beyond the next election
our political editor Beth Rigby reports
now from Pendle in Lancashire
welcome on board this November West
Coast service to Lancashire in the
northwest of England calling at Preston
Lancaster
and on to Pendle a parliamentary
constituency which has long voted
conservative but there are people here
that now have problems with their party
we have watched an absolute Rubble yeah
with no discipline
charging around some of them and
bringing neutral I think it could do
with a good shakeel the last few years
it just just blowing it out of the water
for me from the cost of living
economically we're in a bit of a turmoil
time we need more investment I'll ask
for more investment up in the north to
Illegal immigration and all these people
put up in hotels which is I believe is
six million a day they're not migrants
it's an invasion force and the Health
Service I think the main thing is the
NHS to be quite honest almost 250 miles
south in Westminster this is the first
session we have with the prime minister
of 2023. the pm today grilled on those
subjects intent on telling MPS and
voters he's heard them and is trying to
get on with the job on the economy we
are on track with all of those obr
forecasts inflation to be more than
halved by the end of the year and on the
NHS all our commitments are cut waiting
lists is absolutely Paramount and
protected but it was right getting on
with it but his plan to stop illegal
Boat Crossings undoubtedly the hardest
and most controversial of policy areas
to crack use of the word Invasion to
describe the small boats problem I think
look it's very clear that the scale of
the problem is significant and growing
defend in the language and the
provisions of his new immigration Bill
too with no detention exemption for
children who make illegal Crossings I
don't think we want to create a pull
factor to make it more likely that
children are being making this very
perilous journey in conditions that are
appalling I don't think that's the right
thing to do but it's the people and the
voters here in Pendle that will be the
judge of what's right the first test at
the local elections in May that they'll
lose control of the council you do
you're unfortunately you do Beth Rigby
Sky News in Pendle Lancashire
we will not be bullied the message from
the senior U.S commander of one of the
largest warships in the world just back
from a patrol of the South China Sea
trillions of dollars of trade that's a
third of the world's Maritime shipping
passes through its waterways which are
highly militarized and dotted with
Chinese American and American allied
bases for Beijing sees any U.S presence
in the South China Sea as a direct
threat and has claimed everything around
the so-called nine dash line last week
China said it had prevented an American
warship from operating around the
disputed Paracel Islands the U.S says it
was operating under international law
our Asia correspondent Helen Anne Smith
sent this report from onboard the USS
Nimitz currently dogs near Busan in
South Korea
there are few greater displays of U.S
military might its aircraft carriers are
still the best in the world and where
they move the world pays attention
[Applause]
the USS Nimitz is one of them an
enormous vessel a floating city of sorts
but its presence in this region is
designed to be noticed by one power in
particular China it's increasingly
assertive competitor so the total strike
group in general we have about 7 000
personnel Lieutenant Ben bashong has
served in the U.S Navy for seven years
he and his colleagues know that tensions
here are high and their mission
important keeping the big picture kind
of helping keep a free and open
indo-pacific and I would just say we're
always ready and we're always training
so if uh if we ever get called we're
ready to respond
and being ready has rarely felt more
pressing the Face-Off with China has
multiple fronts almost all are becoming
more fraught
[Music]
indeed China sees this region as its
backyard its Navy's now the largest in
the world and it's making that felt
these pictures shot by a USG to just one
example a Chinese fighter flying
provocatively close it all means says
the Admiral commanding this carrier that
U.S presence here matters China would
say that the US is trying to contain it
what do you say to that allegation yeah
we yeah we do not seek
National Norms again that we all prosper
from there is so much about the rising
tension with China that is invisible and
covert this is designed to be the exact
opposite the message is very clear that
any escalation would come with grave
consequences there's a real sense here
that that message has never been more
needed
displays of Allegiance are also
important here China's conduct is
driving many Asian Nations closer to the
US and each other this region is
increasingly fractured the stakes
increasingly High Helena Smith Sky News
in Busan South Korea
well that was Sky News at 10 coming up
we'll take a first look at tomorrow's
newspapers in the Press preview
including this story on the front of the
financial times their headline hunt to
provide fresh cash injection for NHS pay
deal but teachers rail intensifies well
tonight we're joined by the journalist
and broadcaster Jenny cleanman and the
home Affairs editor of the times Matt
Dayton back in just a moment
[Music]
thank you